our friend John Hamre returned to the
show how are you John hey I'm here
oh good job you good you know what I
think it's funny and I didn't really put
this together but I think the NFL is
simply trolling me because they now had
both franchises that left my hometown of
st. Louis on all or nothing and had me
do the voiceover I think it's a not so
subtle slap in the face
well uh I went along with it well here's
the here's the you silver lining John is
I think we flat out run out of teams at
left st. Louis for you to narrate
they're all enough errors
the NBA comes calling and they have the
Hawks or the spirits I think I think
you're right or the major indoor soccer
league steamers that's right we
unfortunately named st. Louis steamers
hey boy what did they play jungle what
is this dear apparently they're in the
MISL Major Indoor Soccer League well
that was a big dat
that's right watch a soccer played on a
hockey rink hey maybe maybe what we
could do John is get one of those
old-school st. Louis Cardinals annual
videos and will erase Bob Costas track
and you can do you could do like the Jim
Hart years you can redo it John what do
you think of that idea Jim Hart yeah
there were a ton of highlights from
seventies in the a football Cardinals
over lunch even so well how did I reach
oh I'm good man you were so up mean that
baby driver you know first of all I'll
be honest I was thrown off a little bit
because there are no babies actually
driving in this film John you know no
there are and I you know when I first
started the movie I'm like okay this is
going to be a really fun movie about a
prodigy infant golf you know golf
prodigy and I'm like I'd love to see a
little kid with like a 38-inch driver
just peeing at high and letting it fly
but I was by about the fourth or fifth
page I realized oh oh oh okay it's a
different different thing oh my god
no we're super happy with it the other
reviews
be great and I heard Lee said on the
segment before about it and people I
think are really excited to see it it's
it's uh it's not a few qual and it's not
a reboot and it's not uh you know it's
just an original story with some
interesting folks in it told in a really
cool way it's an action film kind of set
music and the action as you well know
and it is it's very intense and there's
some funny parts to it and some really
scary parts to it too but they also it's
a real it's a real interesting unique
movie and I think for some reason people
are are into into seeing something that
they haven't seen before in some version
or others yeah and I want to you know I
don't want to spoil anything for anybody
who hasn't seen it yet or doesn't know
about it yet but you just bring up how
the music it's so important because you
know when they see the actor who's
playing the baby driver ansel elgort and
he's got ear buds in his ear it's just
he's constantly listening to music that
sometimes actually matches up with the
beat of the acting or the action that's
on the screen or it just enhances
everything and you mentioned how you
read the script how does that read how
did you how did you know what would be
such a grosser part of that it's
interesting you know it was good I was I
was kind of a first person to fall on t
like I'd never drew for close to ten
years now and and and she has long had
this book kicking around for almost 20
and he gave me a version edit and then
said but but I want to give it to you
with these lippies tracks included until
you had had a little attachment on the
on the PDF file that was all these all
these songs well I didn't know half of
them but I was like we managed if it's
all about he's like well whenever you
see a little thing in the script it says
track whatever play that track okay and
so you're reading a script mettlesome
you click a thing and then you read in
the description of a chase scene and you
know bell-bottoms is going on or
Brighton Rock or any one of these like
really cool
versions of songs that you kind of think
you've heard before or samples that
you've heard before the music is
phenomenal and it's not just a rehash of
like old age pop songs that are funny
because they're ironic it's they're
actually interesting new songs from
older bank might not heard of so it's a
departure in that way too you know it's
not it's not just even though even the
music side of it was kind of their
curated with with great intention by
Edgar and you know and then there's one
scene again I'm not try not to spoil it
where it's particularly intense and you
being a badass in this movie and a nasty
character and it involves a Barry White
song that normally wouldn't be the
soundtrack to the scene it's it really
is awesome John and I could not
recommend it any thanks for seeing it ya
know I can't I can't implore people
enough to go out and see it I really do
think especially I'm in Atlanta right
now and it is pouring rain and it's
supposed to pour all holiday weekend but
I mean if there is a if you're in a hot
part of the country go to the movie
theater and see this movie it's it's a
and a half of your life but you will
really enjoy it's great it will also be
numb sweaty jon hamm joining me here on
the red eyes and show I'm about to make
the segue
are you ready John I don't want you to
get hurt ready all right here we go now
let's move to baby quarterbacks and
Jared Goff everybody hey now oh boy look
now I tell you thrower I take the baby
thrower even better even better or baby
spiral arm over he could be a driver of
the football he could be sure Yaya's
baby two-minute drill baby drive you
drive to try to dress in minutes you
could do that long way to go
sure but the segues complete at the very
least all or nothing
Amazon Prime video it's available for
streaming today there was actually a
very moving video that was tweeted out I
know you're not on Twitter of Jeff
Fisher informing his coaching staff that
he had been fired and and Mike
Singletary is involved the scene it's
really intense what was it like from
your perspective doing the narrating of
the Los Angeles Rams
we Maltese I got to say the thing I
really love
all or nothing is it's not hard not
right it's not the thing where you don't
know what's going on like this is this
is kind of a recap of a season that
we've already seen but you get this like
incredibly bird dive view of what goes
on behind the singing and the stuff that
you really go and that's a perfect
example of a rich like you see this
thing and you go oh man like you know
you've seen ten episodes of these guys
going through it with this guy and you
know from from other stuff you know
about of living getting through
preseason and let them do all that stuff
and you just stay put like the guy it's
time for the guy to go and everyone's
like well now what and it's devastating
for everybody involved I mean even you
know even the image from the ownership
standpoint you understand why they hang
onto these coaches for so long because
you know you don't want to pull the
trigger too soon
these guys are family they go through
the fire together and and and there's a
trust that's built up and there's a
there's a shorthand and there's a lot of
intangibles that are there and don't you
ever want to pull that trigger too early
and then of course sometimes business
being what it is you have to do it so I
think the Rams are an interesting point
right now and I think to your point that
was that was what was so also look
emotional about that thing was just
watching the every video from all from
all points of view and that's the cool
thing about the show like you get you
get a look into this crazy business of
the NFL that everyone has some kind of
emotional connection to but you get a
real in-depth look at it that's why I
love doing it so which team do you root
for the Arizona Cardinals John is that
the team that you kind of pay attention
to which would ideally kind and I guess
I really don't root for any T one team
in particular I kind of root for good
games and always be underdog but that's
pretty much it okay and and that new
stadium that's down there in Atlanta
looks ridiculous it looks spectacular
well you're mentioning was my voice
credits you conspicuously neglected to
mention that I am the York 11 voice of
mercedes-benz mm-hmm new home of the
Atlanta Falcons so I may be
contractually obligated to roof in the
balconies huh yeah
Stadium is a unbelievable I just saw
like a whole like 3d mock-up like
literally I just came been doing
voiceover yeah and they had this whole
like virtual reality mockable thing
educators spectacular I heard that
they're dead dissing Adium origami yeah
but the yeah it does you're right it
does look like a like a nest is really
what I think they're going for and then
the the Indian Stadium I always call a
diamond vision that just shows you my I
guess my own eyes well yeah plaster dome
here yeah right yes let them play let
the Toros and the Bears play hey let
them play
god bless William Devane what a great
manager he was for the Bad News Bears
huh oh he really was no animal the Bears
Chico's Bail Bonds couldn't evade it
better that's right but I guess the the
in Stadium of the big screen goes around
like a like a ribbon around the entire
stadium I can't wait to see that yeah
yeah hey look I'm looking forward to all
or nothing and we had Andy Samberg on
before wanted me send his best to you
since you're a voice of all his
documentaries on HBO so yes HBO Sports
marketer indeed it's one it's very funny
are taking or finally taking on big
cycling with Mike Tyson and phylicia
rashad the only way it can be taken on
with my elegans are going to be very
angry of us as home take care of traffic
and congrats again on baby driver John
it truly is a special movie and I loved
it it started and then it ended and I
had no idea how long the movie was it
was that it was great really oh that's
great news welcome for them for the
record of 112 you know this you get
three popcorn you'll enjoy it it's
fantastic I'm not kidding I'm you know
me for many many years you know I'm not
an effusive guy but this is one that I'm
I'm very proud of and I think people are
really going to enjoy kind of like
holiday weekend escapist entertainment
and driving the 405 was a different
experience today seriously like I was
watching the traffic in front of me with
a different eye with a totally different
eye or feeling it I love it I was I
really was and thanks for calling back
in
closure on phone calls when calls drop
out John so thanks for calling back
understand if no one no one likes to
drop phone call rich please
you take care of John well chat soon
alright my best to the family and that's
always like to talk to you and thanks
for seeing it so you bet that's John
Hammond
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen show up follow all the information
you see right here on the Rich Eisen
show